with that ambassador Sandlin you are now
recognized for your opening statement
Thank You mr. chairman and thank you
ranking member newness I appreciate the
opportunity to speak again to the
members of this committee first let me
offer my thanks to the men and women of
the u.s. Department of State who have
committed their professional lives to
support the foreign policy work of the
United States in particular I want to
thank my staff at the US mission to the
European Union your integrity dedication
and hard work often performed without
public acclaim or recognition serve as a
shining example of true public service
and I am personally grateful to work
beside you each and every day it is my
honor to serve as the US ambassador to
the European Union the US mission to the
EU is the direct link between the United
States and the European Union and its
members
America's longest standing allies and
one of the largest economic bloc's in
the world every day I work to support a
strong united and peaceful Europe
strengthening our ties with Europe
serves both American and European goals
as we together promote political
stability and economic prosperity around
the world
I expect that few Americans have heard
my name before these events so before I
begin my substantive testimony please
let me share some of my personal
background my parents fled Europe during
the Holocaust escaping the atrocities of
that time my parents left Germany for
Uruguay and then in 1953 emigrated to
Seattle Washington where I was born and
raised like so many immigrants my family
was eager for freedom and hungry for
opportunity they raised my sister and me
to be humble hard-working and patriotic
and I am forever grateful for the
sacrifices they made on our behalf
public service has always been important
to me as a lifelong Republican I have
contributed to initiatives of both
Republican and Democratic
administrations in 2003 I served as a
member of the transition team for Oregon
Democratic governor Ted cool and Gauss
key governor Cullen Gauss key also
appointed me to serve on various
statewide boards in 2007 President
George W Bush appointed me as a member
of the Commission on White House fellows
I worked with President Bush on
charitable events for his Foundation's
military service initiative and I also
worked briefly with former Vice
President Joe Biden's office in
connection with the vice president's
nationwide and anti-cancer initiative at
a local Northwest Hospital and of course
the highest honor in my public life came
when President Trump asked me to serve
as the United States ambassador to the
European Union the Senate confirmed me
as an ambassador on a bipartisan voice
vote
and I assumed the role in Brussels on
July 9th 2018 although today is my first
public testimony on the Ukraine matters
this is not my first time cooperating
with this committee as you know I've
already provided 10 hours of deposition
testimony and I did so despite
directives from the White House and the
State Department that I refused to
appear as many others have done I agreed
to testify because I respect the gravity
of the moment and I believe I have an
obligation to account fully for my role
in these events but I also must
acknowledge that this process has been
challenging and in many respects less
than fair I have not
accessed all of my phone records State
Department emails and many many other
State Department documents and I was
told I could not work with my EU staff
to pull together the relevant files and
information having access to the State
Department materials would have been
very helpful to me in trying to
reconstruct with whom I spoke and met
and when and what was said as ambassador
I've had hundreds of meetings and calls
with individuals but I'm not a
note-taker
or a memo writer never have been my job
requires that I speak with heads of
state senior government officials
members of the cabinet the president
almost each and every day talking with
foreign leaders might be memorable to
some people but this is my job I do it
all the time my lawyers and I have made
multiple requests to the State
Department and the White House for these
materials yet these materials were not
provided to me and they have also
refused to share these materials with
this committee these documents are not
classified and in fairness and in
fairness should have been made available
in the absence of these materials my
memory admittedly has not been perfect
and I have no doubt that a more fair
open and orderly process of allowing me
to read the State Department records and
other materials would have made this
process far more transparent I don't
intend to repeat my prior opening
statement or attempt to summarize 10
hours of previous deposition testimony
however a few critical points have been
obscured by noise over the last few days
and weeks and I'm worried that the
bigger picture is being ignored so let
me make a few key points
first secretary Perry ambassador Volker
and I worked with mr. Rudy Giuliani on
Ukraine matters at the express direction
of the President of the United States we
did not want to work with mr. Giuliani
simply put we were playing the hand we
were dealt we all understood that if we
refused to work with mr. Giuliani we
would lose a very important opportunity
to cement relations between the United
States and Ukraine so we followed the
president's orders second although we
disagreed with the need to involve mr.
Giuliani at the time we did not believe
that his role was improper as I
previously testified if I had known of
all of mr. Giuliani's dealings or his
associations with individuals some of
whom are now under criminal indictment I
personally would not have acquiesced to
his participation still given what we
knew at the time what we were asked to
do did not appear to be wrong third let
me say precisely because we did not
think that we were engaging in improper
behavior we made every effort to ensure
that the relevant decision-makers at the
National Security Council and the State
Department knew the important details of
our efforts the suggestion that we were
engaged in some irregular or rogue
diplomacy is absolutely false I have now
identified certain State Department
emails and messages that provide
contemporaneous support for my view
these emails show that the leadership of
the State Department the National
Security Council and the White House
were all informed about the Ukraine
efforts from May 23rd 2019 until the
security aid was released on September
11th 2019 I will quote from some of
those messages with you shortly
fourth as I testified previously as I
testified previously mr. Giuliani's
requests were a quid pro quo for
arranging a White House visit for
President Solinsky mr. Giuliani demanded
that Ukraine make a public statement
announcing the investigations of the
2016 election DNC server and burry smih
mr. Giuliani was expressing the desires
of the President of the United States
and we knew these investigations were
important to the president fifth in July
in August of 2019 we learned that the
White House had also suspended security
aid to Ukraine I was adamantly opposed
to any suspension of aid I was adamantly
suppo adamantly opposed to any
suspension of aid as the Ukrainians
needed those funds to fight against
Russian aggression
I tried diligently to ask why the aid
was suspended but I never received a
clear answer still haven't to this day
in the absence of any credible
explanation for the suspension of aid I
later came to believe that the
resumption of security aid would not
occur until there was a public statement
from Ukraine committing to the
investigations of the 2016 elections and
bery smih as mr. Giuliani had demanded I
shared concerns of the potential quid
pro quo regarding the security aid with
Senator Ron Johnson and I also shared my
concerns with the Ukrainians
finally at all times I was acting in
good faith I was acting in good faith as
a presidential appointee I followed the
directions of the president we worked
with mr. Giuliani because the president
directed us to do so we had no desire to
set any conditions we had no desire to
set any conditions on the Ukrainians
indeed my own personal view which I
shared repeatedly with others was that
the White House and security security
assistance should have proceeded without
preconditions of any kind we were
working to overcome the problems given
the facts as they existed our only
interest and my only interest was to
advance long-standing US policy and to
support Ukraine's fragile democracy now
let
provide additional details specifically
about Ukraine and my involvement first
my very first days as ambassador to the
EU which was starting back in July of
2018 Ukraine has featured prominently in
my broader portfolio Ukraine's political
and economic development are critical to
the long-standing and long-lasting
stability of Europe
moreover the conflict in eastern Ukraine
and Crimea remains one of the most
significant security crisis for Europe
and the United States our efforts to
counterbalance and aggressive Russia
depend in substantial part on a strong
Ukraine on April 21st 2019 Vladimir
zalenski was elected president of
Ukraine and in an historic election with
the express support of secretary Pompeo
I attended president zelinsky's
inauguration on May 20th as part of the
US delegation which was led by Energy
Secretary Rick Perry the US delegation
also included senator Johnson Ukraine
special envoy Volcker and Lieutenant
Colonel Alex Vinland of the National
Security Council my attendance at
President zelinsky's inauguration was
not my first involvement with Ukraine as
I testified previously just four days
after assuming my post as ambassador in
July of 2018
I received an official delegation from
the government of then Ukraine president
Petro poroshenko the meeting took place
at the US mission in Brussels and was
pre-arranged by my career EU mission
staff and I've had several meetings
since then in Brussels later in February
of 2019 I worked well with US Ambassador
Marie Ivanovitch in making my first a
fish
visit to Ukraine for a u.s. Navy visit
to the strategic Black Sea port of
Odessa and the reason I raise these
prior Ukraine activities the meetings in
Brussels my visit to Odessa is to
emphasize that Ukraine has been a part
of my portfolio from my very first days
as the US ambassador any claim that I
somehow muscled my way into the Ukraine
relationship is simply false
during the Solinsky inauguration on May
20th the US delegation developed a very
positive view of the Ukraine government
we were impressed by president
solinsky's desire to promote a stronger
relationship with the United States we
admired his commitment to reform and we
were excited about the possibility of
Ukraine making the changes necessary to
support a greater Western economic
investment and we were excited that
Ukraine might after years and years of
lip service finally get serious about
addressing its own well known corruption
problems with that enthusiasm we
returned to the White House on May 23rd
to brief President Trump we advise the
president of the strategic importance of
Ukraine and the value of strengthening
the relationship with president Solinsky
to support this reformer we asked the
White House for two things first a
working phone call between presidents
Trump and zalenski and second a working
oval office visit in our view both were
vital to cementing the us Ukraine
relationship demonstrating support for
Ukraine in the face of Russian
aggression and advancing broader US
foreign policy interests
unfortunately President Trump was
skeptical he expressed concerns that the
Ukrainian government was not serious
about reform and he even mentioned that
Ukraine tried to take him down in the
last election in response to our
persistent efforts in that meeting to
change his views
president Trump directed us to quote
talk with rudy' we understood that talk
with Rudy meant talk with mr. Rudy
Giuliani the president's personal lawyer
let me say again we weren't happy with
the president's directive to talk with
Rudy we did not want to involve mr.
Giuliani I believe then as I do now that
the men and women of the State
Department not the president's personal
lawyer should take responsibility for
Ukraine matters nonetheless based on the
president's Direction we were faced with
a choice we could abandon the efforts to
schedule the White House phone call in a
White House visit between presidents
Trump and zolensky which was
unquestionably
in our foreign policy interest or we
could do as president Trump had directed
and talked with Rudy we chose the latter
course not because we liked it but
because it was the only constructive
path open to us
over the course of the next several
months secretary Perry ambassador Volker
and I were in communication with mr.
Giuliani secretary Perry volunteered to
make the initial calls with mr. Giuliani
given their prior relationship
ambassador Volker made several of the
early calls and generally informed us of
what was discussed I first communicated
with mr. Giuliani in early August
several months later mr. Giuliani
emphasized that the president wanted a
public statement from president Solinsky
committing Ukraine to look into the
corruption issues mr. Giuliani
specifically mentioned the 2016 election
including the DNC server and burry smih
as to topics of importance to the
president we kept the leadership of the
State Department and the NSC informed of
our activities and that included
communications with Secretary of State
Pompeo his counselor Ulrich Breck bull
his executive secretary Lisa Kenna and
also communications with Ambassador
Bolton dr. hill Mr Morrison and their
staff at the NSC they knew what we were
doing and why on July 10th 2019 senior
Ukrainian national security officials
met with ambassador Bolton ambassador
Volcker dr. hill secretary Perry myself
and several others in Washington DC
during that meeting we all discussed the
importance of the two action items
identified earlier one
you
tenth meeting was a positive step toward
our shared goals while I am now aware of
accounts of the meeting from dr. hill
and lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh their
recollections of those events simply
don't square with my own or with those
of ambassador Volker or secretary Perry
I recall mentioning the prerequisite of
investigations before any White House
call or meeting but I do not recall any
yelling or screaming or abrupt
terminations as others have said instead
after the meeting
ambassador Bolton walked outside with
our group and we all took some great
pictures together outside on the White
House lawn more important those
recollections of protests do not square
with the documentary record of our
interactions with the NSC in the days
and weeks that followed we kept the NSC
apprised of our efforts including
specifically our efforts to secure a
public statement from the Ukrainians
that would satisfy president Trump's
concerns for example on July 13th and
this is three days after that July 10th
meeting I emailed Tim Morrison he had
just taken over dr. Hills post as the
NSC eurasia director and I met him that
day for the first time I wrote to Mr
Morrison with these words the call
between zalenski and POTUS President of
the United States should happen before
7:21 which is the parliamentary
elections in Ukraine sole purpose is for
zalenski to give POTUS assurances of new
sheriff in town
corruption ending unbundling moving
forward and and I emphasize any hampered
investigations will be allowed to move
forward transparently goal is for POTUS
to invite him to Oval volker Perry
Bolton and I strongly recommend
Mr Morrison acknowledged and said thank
you and specifically noted that he was
tracking these issues again there was no
secret regarding moving forward and the
discussion of investigations moreover I
have reviewed other State Department
documents some of which are not
currently in the public domain
detailing mr. Giuliani's efforts for
example on July 10th the very same day
that ambassador Volcker secretary Perry
and I were meeting with the Ukraine
officials in Washington ambassador
Taylor received a communication that mr.
Giuliani was still talking with
Ukrainian prosecutor yuriy lutsenko in
whatsapp messages with ambassador
Volcker and I ambassador Taylor wrote to
us as follows just had a meeting with
Andre and Vadim referring to Ukraine
Foreign Minister Vadim pristiq Oh Taylor
said the Ukrainians were quote very
concerned about what lysenko told them
that according to our G meaning rudy
giuliani
the zalenski POTUS meeting will not
happen Volcker responded good grief
please tell the deme to let the official
US government representatives speak for
the u.s. loot senko has his own
self-interest here taylor confirmed that
he had communicated that message to the
ukrainians and he added i briefed ulrich
this afternoon on this referring to
State Department counselor Ulrich
breakfa again everyone's in the loop
three things are critical about this
whatsapp exchange first while the
Ukrainians were in Washington at the
White House mr. Giuliani was
communicating with the Ukrainians
without our knowledge ambassador Taylor
ambassador Volker and I were all
surprised by this second mr. Giuliani
was
unike ting with the reportedly corrupt
Ukrainian prosecutor loot Senko and
discussing whether a Solinsky Trump
meeting was going to happen again
without our knowledge and third with
this alarming news ambassador Taylor
briefed Ulrich breakfa who is the
councillor to Secretary of State Pompeo
and even as late as September 24th of
this year secretary Pompeo was directing
kurt volker to speak with mr. Giuliani
in a whatsapp message kurt volker told
me in part spoke with rudy / guidance
from s s is the State Department's
official designator for the secretary
spoke with Rudy / guidance from s look
we tried our best to fix the problem
while keeping the State Department and
the NSC closely apprised of the
challenges we faced on July 25th
presidents Trump and zalenski had their
official call I was not on the call and
I don't think I was invited to be on the
call
in fact I first read the transcript on
September 25th the day it was publicly
released all I had heard at that time
was that the call had gone well looking
back I find it very odd very odd that
neither I nor ambassador Taylor nor
ambassador Volcker ever received a
detailed readout of that call with the
Biden references now there are people
who say they had concerns about the call
but no one shared any concerns about the
call with me at the time which frankly
would have been very helpful to know
on July 26th ambassador Taylor
ambassador Volker and I were all in Kiev
to meet with President Solinsky the
timing of that trip immediately after
the call between presidents Trump and
zalenski was entirely entirely
coincidental the key of meetings had
been scheduled well before the date that
the White House finally fixed the call
during our key of meeting I do not
recall president Solinsky discussing the
substance of his July 25th call with
President Trump nor did he discuss any
request to investigate Vice President
Biden which we all later learned was
discussed on the July 25th call and this
is consistent with the reported comments
from ambassadors Volcker and Taylor
after the zolensky meeting I also met
with zalenski senior aide Andre Yermak I
don't recall the specifics of our
conversation but I believe the issue of
investigations was probably a part of
that agenda our meeting also on July 26
shortly after our Kiev meetings I spoke
by phone with President Trump the White
House which has finally finally shared
certain call dates and times with my
attorneys confirms this the call lasted
five minutes I remember I was at a
restaurant in Kiev and I have no reason
to doubt that this conversation included
the subject of investigations again
given mr. Giuliani's demand that
president zalenski make a public
statement about investigations
I knew that investigations were
important to President Trump we did not
discuss any classified information other
witnesses have recently shared their
recollection of overhearing this call
for the most part I have no reason to
doubt their accounts it's true that the
president speaks loudly at times and
it's also true I think we primarily
discussed ASAP rocky it's true that the
president likes to use colorful language
anyone who has met with him it for any
reasonable amount of time knows this
well I cannot remember the precise
details again the White House has not
allowed me to see any readouts of that
call and the July 26 call did not strike
me as significant at the time actually
actually I would have been more
surprised if President Trump had not
mentioned investigations particularly
given what we were hearing from mr.
Giuliani about the president's concerns
however I have no recollection of
discussing Vice President Biden or his
son on that call or after the call ended
I know that members of this committee
frequently framed these complicated
issues in the form of a simple question
was there a quid pro quo as I testified
previously with regard to the requested
White House call and the White House
meeting the answer is yes mr. Giuliani
conveyed to secretary Perry ambassador
Volker and others that President Trump
wanted a public statement from President
Solinsky committing to investigations of
burry smih and the 2016 election mr.
Giuliani expressed those requests
directly to the Ukrainians and mr.
Giuliani also expressed those requests
directly to us we all understood that
these prerequisites for the White House
call and the right White House meeting
reflected president Trump's desires and
requirements within my State Department
emails there is a July 19th email this
email was sent this email was sent to
secretary Pompeo secretary Perry Brian
McCormack who is Secretary Perry's chief
of staff at the time miss Kenna who is
the acting pardon me who is the
executive Secretariat for Secretary
Pompeo chief of staff Mulvaney and mr.
Mulvaney's senior advisor Rob Blair
out of senior officials a lot of senior
officials here is my exact quote from
that email I talked to zalenski just now
he is prepared to receive POTUS call
will assure him that he intends to run a
fully transparent investigation and will
turn over every stone he would greatly
appreciate a call prior to Sunday so
that he can put out some media about a
friendly and productive call no details
prior to Ukraine election on Sunday
chief of staff Mulvaney responded I
asked the NSC to set it up for tomorrow
everyone was in the loop it was no
secret
everyone was informed via email on July
19th days before the presidential call
as I communicated to the team
I told president Solinsky in advance
that assurances to run a fully
transparent investigation and turn over
every stone were necessary in his call
with President Trump on July 19th in a
whatsapp message between ambassador
Taylor ambassador Volker and me
ambassador Volcker stated had breakfast
with Rudy this morning
that's ambassador Volcker and Rudy
Giuliani teeing up call with your Mac
Monday that senior advisor Andre year
Mac must have helped most important is
froze Alinsky to say that he will help
investigation and address any specific
personnel issues if there are any on
August 10th the next day mr. your Mac
texted me once we have a date which is a
date for the White House meeting we will
call for a press briefing announcing
upcoming visit and outlining vision for
the reboot of the u.s. Ukraine
relationship
including among other things barista and
election meddling in investigations this
is from mr. yer Mac to me the following
day August 11th and this is critical I
sent an email to councillor Breck bull
and Lisa Kenna Lisa Kenna was frequently
used as the pathway to secretary Pompeo
as sometimes he preferred to receive his
emails through her she would print them
out and put them in front of him with
the subject Ukraine
I wrote Mike referring to Mike Pompeo
Kurt and I negotiated a statement from
zalenski to be delivered for our review
in a day or two the contents will
hopefully make the boss happy enough the
boss being the president to authorize an
invitation zalinsky plans to have a big
presser press conference on the openness
subject including specifics next week
all of which referred to the 2016 and
the barista miss Kenna replied Gordon
I'll pass to the secretary thank you
again everyone was in the loop curiously
and this was very interesting to me on
August 26th shortly before his visit to
Kiev ambassador Bolton's office
requested mr. Giuliani's contact
information for me I send ambassador
Bolton the information directly
they requested mr. Giuliani's contact
information on August 26th
I was first informed that the White
House was withholding security aid to
Ukraine during conversations with
ambassador Taylor on July 18th 2019
however as I testified before I was
never able to obtain a clear answer
regarding the specific reason for the
hold whether it was bureaucratic in
nature which often happens or reflected
some other concern in the interagency
process I never participated in any of
the subsequent DoD or do s review
meetings that others have described so I
can't speak to what was discussed in
those meetings nonetheless before the
September 1st Warsaw meeting the
Ukrainians had become aware that
security funds had yet to be dispersed
in the absence of any credible
explanation for the hold I came to the
conclusion that the aid like the White
House visit was jeopardized in
preparation for the September 1 Warsaw
meeting I asked secretary Pompeo whether
a face-to-face conversation between
Trump and zalenski would help to break
the logjam and this was when President
Trump was still intending to travel to
Warsaw specifically on August 22nd I
emailed secretary Pompeo directly
copying Secretariat Kenneth I wrote this
is my email to secretary Pompeo should
we block time in Warsaw for a short pull
aside for POTUS to meet Solinsky I would
ask zalenski
to look him in the eye and tell him that
once Ukraine's new Justice folks are in
place in mid-september that zalenski he
zalenski should be able to move forward
publicly and with confidence on those
issues of importance to POTUS in the US
hopefully that will help break the
logjam
the secretary replied yes I followed up
the next day asking to get 10 to 15
minutes on the Warsaw schedule for this
I said we'd like to know when it's
locked so that I can tell zalenski and
briefed him
executive secretary can I replied I will
try for sure moreover given my concerns
about the security aid I have no reason
to dispute that portion of senator
Johnson's recent letter in which he
recalls conversations he and I had on
August 30th by the end of August my
belief was that if Ukraine did something
to demonstrate a serious intention to
fight corruption and specifically
addressing bery smih and the 2016 then
the hold on military aid would be lifted
there was a September 1st meeting with
President zalenski in Warsaw
unfortunately President trumps
attendance at the Warsaw meeting was
canceled due to Hurricane Dorian vice
president pence attended instead I
mentioned a vice president pence before
the meetings with the Ukrainians that I
had concerns that the delay in aid had
become tied to the issue of
investigations I recall mentioning that
before the zalenski meeting during the
actual meeting president Solinsky raised
the issue of security assistance
directly with vice president pence and
the vice president said that he would
speak to president Trump about it based
on my previous communication with
secretary Pompeo I felt comfortable
sharing my concerns with mr. gyro Mac it
was a very very brief pull-aside
conversation that happened within a few
seconds I told mr. your Mac that I
believe that the resumption of US aid
would likely not occur until Ukraine
took some kind of action on the public
statement that we had been discussing
for many weeks as my other State
Department colleagues have testified
this security aid was critical to
Ukraine's defense and should not have
been delayed I expressed the
view to many during this period but my
goal at the time was to do it was
necessary to get the aid released to
break the logjam I believe that the
public statement we had been discussing
for weeks was essential to advancing
that goal you know I really regret that
the Ukrainians were placed in that
predicament but I do not regret doing
what I could to try to break the logjam
and to solve the problem I mentioned at
the outset that throughout these events
we kept State Department leadership and
others apprised of what we were doing
State Department was fully supportive of
our engagement in Ukraine efforts and
was aware that a commitment to
investigations was among the issues we
were pursuing to provide just two
examples On June 5th the day after the
u.s. EU mission hosted our Independence
Day we did it a month early acting
assistant secretary Phil reaker sent an
email to me to secretary Perry and two
others
forwarding some positive media coverage
of President zelinsky's attendance at
our event mr. Ricca wrote and I quote
this headline underscores the importance
and timeliness of zelinsky's visit to
Brussels and the critical and the
critical perhaps historic role of the
dinner and engagement
Gordon coordinated thank you for your
participation and dedication to this
effort months later on September 3rd I
sent secretary Pompeo an email to
express my appreciation for his joining
a series of meetings in Brussels
following the Warsaw trip I wrote Mike
thanks for schlepping to Europe I think
it was really important and the
chemistry seems promising really
appreciate it
secretary Pompeo replied the next day on
Wednesday September 4th quote all good
you're doing great work keep banging
away
a State Department leadership expressed
total support for our efforts to engage
the new Ukrainian administration look
I've never doubted the strategic value
of strengthening our alliance with
Ukraine and at all times at all times
our efforts were in good faith and fully
transparent to those tasked with
overseeing them our efforts were
reported and approved and not once do I
recall encountering an objection
it remains an honor to serve the people
of the United States as their United
States ambassador to the European Union
I look forward to answering the
committee's questions thank you